citation et on s'arrête un instant sur
la question des responsabilités
la question qui reste pour l'instant
sans réponse
s'agit-il de dérapages individuels ou
bien ces comportements répond-t-il à une
logique d'ensemble plus ou moins
explicite des éléments d'appréciation
avec bernard lebrun jeremy civic 24 ans
policier militaire aux arrêts en irak
accusé de mauvais traitements agressions
et actes indécents envers des
prisonniers sera le premier soldat
américain à comparaître le 19 mai à
bagdad devant une cour martiale
le jeune si vite ce mécanicien dans le
civil est ce que l'on appelle un
réserviste
comme les six autres inculpés il
appartient à cette unité stationnée dans
le mari landes
selon ses collègues aujourd'hui
démobilisés jamais ses hommes n'ont reçu
de formation particulière nous n'avons
pas d'être entraînée pour travailler
dans une prison autrement dit ces
photographies prises à la prison d'abou
ghraïb ne montrerait pas un système
d'interrogatoire mais le dérapage isolé
de soldats non professionnels ayant
perdu la raison sans doute à force de
voir tomber leurs camarades
et pourtant quand après le 11 septembre
2001 les forces américaines envahissent
l'afghanistan pour chasser les talibans
tous les moyens semblent bons fort d'une
opinion publique convaincue qu'ils n'ont
que ce qu'ils méritent
on assiste aux premiers dérapages déjà
apparaissent les cagoules et s'est
attaché dans les avions que partent les
prisonniers talibans pour guantanamo ni
prisonniers de guerre ni inculpée
n'ayant l'assistance d'un avocat
ces détenus sont hors-la-loi guantanamo
dit le général qui le commande est un
laboratoire interrogator nous permettent
d'obtenir chaque jour de précieux
renseignements
coïncidence c'est ce grand spécialiste
du renseignement que le pentagone vient
de nommer à la tête des unités
militaires en charge des prisons
irakiennes et tout spécialement celle
d'abou ghraïb désormais ouverte en
partie à la presse
le guide soldats de préciser que les
interrogatoires dur de une à quatre
heures sans méthode coercitive précisera
le général miller qui dit il est un
adepte de la pratique d'une détention
humaine d'ailleurs selon le général
ces images appartiennent au passé c'est
lui qui a décidé d'abolir la cagoule
pour les prisonniers et